it won't be an exaggeration to call life
in the 21st
century amazing we're used to
smartphones
which help us get connection in any part
of the world
and to artificial intelligence
suggestions prompting us what to check
out
on websites most of us would have
trouble
trying to picture what the world might
look like
even tomorrow and it seems completely
pointless to make any predictions about
opportunities that nearest decades have
in store for us
imagine you have ventured to go to sleep
in an ice chamber
and awake a hundred years from now what
is your perception
of the revealed reality are there any
humans
on the earth or would everyone have
moved to mars for good by that time
due to its comparative closeness to our
planet and similarities of its natural
properties with those of the earth mars
is the most likely candidate
to become a human colony in the
foreseeable future
apart from venus which is potentially
uninhabitable
traveling to the red planet from the
earth takes the least energy
and even though humans cannot survive on
the planet's surface without protective
gear
the conditions for settling there remain
the most favorable
in comparison to those on the other
celestial objects
closest to us
the main objective of colonizing mars
which is planned for this century
is to build a permanent base for
scientific research of the planet
and its satellites this base may later
be used for further colonization of the
asteroid belt
and other more distant planets of the
solar system
besides mars may turn out to be rich
enough in natural resources
due to the fact that there is no free
oxygen in its atmosphere
rich deposits of native metals may be
concealed in its depths
such as copper iron tungsten rhenium
uranium and gold
currently the main obstacle preventing
the mars colonization projects from
taking off
is how to manage to send at least one
colonist crew on a fast
and comparatively cheap journey as for
transporting the entire base
with all necessary resources equipment
and machinery
it is at this point quite unimaginable
you would have heard that in 2016 the
ceo of the american company spacex
elon musk shared his plans for the
exploration of the red planet
and presented a project of an
interplanetary transportation
infrastructure
intended for colonizing mars as soon as
this century
its main components are a reusable
booster rocket
an interplanetary spaceship for
transporting human passengers
and a spaceship refilling modification
the system's concept is based on several
key technologies
that will involve rocketry usability
special tankers for refilling the rocket
in orbit
and the use of methane as fuel methane
can be produced locally
from water and carbon dioxide on mars
all of the engines are supposed to be
chemical
iron thrusters and nuclear options i
talked about in another video
are at this point not being considered
the rocket starship carrying the future
colonists
should have to be the largest ever
rocket constructed by man
with its height reaching 118 meters
its diameter measuring 9 meters and its
launching mass
accounting for 5 000 tons
starship will consist of two parts a
spaceship
and a booster rocket dubbed super heavy
which is needed to help the spaceship
overcome the earth's gravity there will
be a total of 43 rocket engines
installed in both parts
the company is planning a payload bay
with a capacity of up to 100 tons of
payload
to be launched in orbit starship will be
able to land on practically any dense
terrain in the solar system
inside there will be about a thousand
cubic meters of sealed areas
to accommodate 40 cabins for the crew as
well as large common areas
storage space a galley and a solar storm
shelter
elon musk has already claimed starship
to be the most
challenging project of spacex with the
company intending to concentrate
all its resources on putting it into
practice
the first step to the colonization of
mars taken back in 2018
was the construction of a spaceport in
texas with the view to carrying out
tests of boosters and new types of
rockets
the choice of texas was predefined by
the fact that spacex will be able to
ship
bulky rocket components to the assembly
site straight from los angeles
besides texan authorities willingly
provide financial support to the company
as the spaceport offers a big number of
vacancies
in this state however the main reason
for building the spaceport there
is explained by the geographical
position of texas
it is located in the southern part of
the usa
and as it is closer to the equator it
may greatly help save up fuel
the earth's rotation will greatly boost
the rocket's acceleration
on liftoff tests of future
interplanetary rockets began back in
since then the first prototype has been
successfully tested
the second prototype has passed the seal
test
the third has been tested by liquid
nitrogen pressurization
and the construction of the lower part
of the ship has been tested in the
fourth prototype
the last test was carried out in early
april 2020
with the fifth prototype tested in
cryogenic temperatures
and high pressure at the moment the
company's intention is to carry on with
the tests
and to develop the rocket's new versions
after all tests have been completed by
spacex
elon musk plans to move on to the next
stage
at this stage starship will first have
to orbit the earth
depleting all of its fuel supply during
the process
after that the rocket will be refilled
by space tankers
once the refilling is completed the
spacecraft will set out on its journey
to mars
these launches are planned to take place
twice a year
when the distance between mars and the
earth is the shortest
having said that the summer of 2022
is the most favorable time for that with
the estimated flight time
from several months to a year thus
landing on mars may take place as soon
as at the beginning of 2023
on the first flights to mars supplies
and machinery necessary for future
missions will be transported
apart from that the existence of water
sources in the areas of key interest on
the planet
will need to be confirmed a manned
flight
will herald the beginning of the third
stage a spacecraft with humans
may optimistically arrive at the red
planet as soon as in 2025
in order to build a martian colony the
human settlers on mars are going to need
sources of food
machinery for water extraction and
refinement
and systems for transforming local
resources into fuel and oxygen
necessary for their return back to the
earth the first
humans on mars will have to lay the
groundwork for future martian
infrastructure
for instance build a launch pad or a
runway for safer landings
of future manned missions the first
spacecraft are likely to serve as homes
for the astronauts
according to elon musk a permanent
martian base
may be ready in 2028
the martian living quarters are supposed
to provide sufficient protection from
radiation
prevent martian sand from getting blown
in and sustained temperatures
adequate for life to date there are
several models of martian living
quarters which are being tested in the
gobi desert
on the slopes of hawaiian volcanoes and
in the arizona desert
the final stage of the colonization will
involve the construction of the first
martian colony that would comprise
fuel production facilities greenhouses
for growing food
and everything needed to support human
life
after that elon musk hopes to send about
a million
people to mars he emphasizes that the
cost of one ticket
must not be over two hundred thousand
dollars
the head of spacex is certain that if
all goes well
life on mars shouldn't feel much
different from that on our planet
and future colonists will enjoy the same
kind of pizza places and bars
as we have on our earth in theory
humans on mars may not always have to
live in a cold desert
spacex are currently working on a
concept of a possible terraforming of
the red planet
in the distant future in order to
achieve that
it will take melting ice caps at the
martian poles
being rich in carbon they are likely to
facilitate
unleashing the hypothetical terraforming
process
if it doesn't happen the colonists will
have to carry on their work in the
atmospheric pressure of one percent of
that of the earth
they will constantly be harassed by
powerful radiation
which reaches the surface of mars
unthwarted
as there is practically no atmosphere on
mars to speak of
these people will not be able to stay
there without special machinery and
protective spacesuits
thus their efforts to build a
self-sufficient colony
will simply turn into a struggle to
survive
in his recent speech elon musk
traditionally compared the colonization
of mars
with populating america he also added
that unfortunately today there is no
guarantee
that the first colonists will be able to
safely return to the earth
scientists will probably devise ways to
adapt to hazards on mars
in the next several years or else it
will be the colonists
who will have to make this discovery and
their contribution
will be reliable groundwork for
spreading life
on an entire planet
dear friends such prospects can't but
amaze
that's why i'm here to tell you about
them
every new episode on the cosmo channel
is the result of a lot of work
and it takes time and effort and of
course motivation
encouraged by your likes if you enjoy
what we do
don't forget to hit the button under
this video to subscribe
and then every one of us will get at
least a tiny bit closer to the amazing
world
of our future
[Music]
you